Michael Audrey Myers was born in 1957 as
the second and final child of Edith and
Donald Myers after his nine-year-old
sister Judith in this video I'm
analyzing the latest version of the
Michael Myers character from the 40-year
timeline that includes Halloween
Halloween 2018 Halloween kills and
Halloween ends most cities have a Union
Station or joint station where most of
the routes connect in the case of the
Halloween Express that is Halloween
1978. from there you can go down the
original route where Michael was
involved with the cult worshiping an
ancient demon you can go down the
20-year timeline route where Michael
escapes after getting blown up by Dr
Loomis or you can go down to the 40-year
timeline route where Michael is captured
and locked up for four decades so his
origin in this timeline is mostly a
familiar one but not entirely things
would take a Twist in this video you'll
learn how this iteration of Michael
Myers was modeled after Jaws the meaning
of his signature traits like the head
tilt and the answer to the one question
on everyone's mind is this the end of
Michael Myers to find out stick around
to the end of this video
[Music]
history one of the goals set by
co-writers David Gordon green and Danny
McBride was to make the Michael Myers
character scary again to do this they
looked back to the original which
included no familial relations no
complex backstories and no
over-explanations of the character
producers Jason Blum and David Gordon
green have both described their approach
as walking in line between honoring the
old and twisting that into something new
for example Michael's look and body
language are closer to that of the
original than ever before but they
aren't opposed to ramping up the blood
and gore to keep up with the modern
slasher something we didn't really see
during Michael's first appearance in the
more conservative 1970s the most
important direction for a contemporary
Boogeyman was to reintroduce the
Mystique and that comes across in the
way that he's written acted and even in
the design of his iconic Mass
something scary about someone committing
those kind of violent acts with no
emotion at all and that's what that mask
does you can project your own things
that frighten you onto that mask special
effects designer Chris Nelson created
the mask with the goal of preserving The
Melancholy of the character and many
fans agree that it was effective in
using a blank slate to bring back the
horror of what might be other timelines
mess up the illusion of emotionlessness
by showing his face making him cry
explaining his childhood in great detail
or in some cases just using masks that
look way too surprised or too angry I'd
like to know as little about him and his
history and abilities as possible the
director offered in an interview with
halloweenmovies.com I think there was a
reason that he was called to the shape
in the original because in some ways
he's more of an Essence than he is a
traditional character while this is a
valid point I also think the very
practice of doing a sequel Trilogy
results in new lore being added to the
character this one goes back to the idea
that Michael Myers is human but with a
supernatural Edge he is nearly
invincible
the character who is between a human
being and the Supernatural and he's a
human being we need to understand and
with more scenes to study we can start
to recognize patterns and draw a few
conclusions about him without disrupting
the mysterious Allure that has made him
a legend for so many decades we've got a
lot of ground to cover so let's get into
it
s child Michael was an outcast while he
didn't exhibit any alarming Behavior he
didn't seem to exhibit much Behavior at
all this caused some adults to feel bad
for him including the mother of a boy in
his class Peter McCabe Mrs McCabe would
make her son go over to Michael's house
to play but Michael would just spend all
of his time staring out of his sister's
window at the age of six years old on
October 31st 1963 Michael's parents go
out for the evening and his older sister
is hanging out with her boyfriend
leaving him unsupervised after seeing
Judith and her boyfriend go upstairs he
takes a knife from the kitchen and heads
up himself Judith is combing your hair
when the boy creeps up and stabs her
several times he simply walks outside
and stands in front of the house as his
parents come home to discover his crime
he was taken into the custody of the
Illinois Department of Public Safety
Juvenile Justice on November 1st
officials at the time stated he likely
would not be charged with first-degree
murder pending a psychological
evaluation after the evaluation it was
decided he would undergo psychiatric
treatment Michael is labeled as patient
number a 2201 sentenced to Smith's Grove
sanitarium and assigned to a
psychiatrist named Dr Samuel Loomis his
initial stay at Smith's Grove lasted 15
years none of which is documented in the
Halloween films Michael Audrey Meyer
shall be brought before the court on the
day of his 21st birthday where he shall
be tried as an adult for those who are
wondering this scene is one of the extra
scenes shot for the television version
of the original 1978 film long story
short they wanted to add scenes to fit a
television time slot with more
commercials the question is if these
scenes are still canon in the 40-year
timeline because in Halloween 2018 we
see this Michael's middle initial is a
the name Michael Audrey Myers comes from
these made for TV scenes it's totally
possible that this was intended to be an
Easter egg though because another made
for TV scene shows Michael wrote the
word sister on his door before breaking
out of Smith's Grove this suggests that
he broke out to go after his sister Lori
which he does in Halloween too however
Michael and Laurie are not siblings in
the 40-year timeline co-writer Danny
McBride has talked about this change I
was pushing for the removal of the
familial mythology setup in Halloween 2
right off the bat I just felt like it
was an area where he wasn't quite as
scary anymore it seemed too personalized
the idea was that the the audience knows
they're not related to Michael so they
didn't have anything to worry about but
if he's just going after random people
everyone has a reason to be afraid it's
possible that Michael wrote sister in
reference to Judith whose tombstone he
steals after breaking out so you could
make an argument either way as to the
canonosity of these added scenes my take
is that they're not part of the 40-year
timeline the extra scenes were shot
using the crews from Halloween too and
they aired in 1980 right before
Halloween too so it's pretty clear that
they're meant to set up that movie
Halloween 2018 takes a strong stance in
that it only acknowledges Halloween one
going so far as to say that Halloween 2
was just made up wasn't it her brother
who like cold-blooded murdered all those
teenagers no that's just a bit that some
people made up to make him feel better I
think in 1978 after Michael turns 21 he
was due back in court for re-evaluation
but when Dr Loomis and his associate
nurse Marion Chambers arrived to pick
him up he and several other patients
were on the loose Michael stole their
car and escaped into the knights in
Warren County this version of the
Michael Myers character plays into his
status as an urban legend and it makes
sense because how Halloween 2018 kills
and ends are aimed at a new generation a
generation who has probably heard of
Michael Myers but not yet experienced
him for themselves much like an urban
legend think about the popular urban
legends of our culture there are always
repeating elements and symptoms Bloody
Mary will appear if you say her name
into a mirror three times with only a
candle's light Slenderman will appear
nestled in forest trees and cause
glitches in video equipment the lights
will flicker on and off before the
appearance of The Hash Slinging Slasher
in Michael's case he comes out around
Halloween night surrounded by a fleet of
wraith-like mental patients there are
many other symptoms of the urban legend
that are seen by multiple generations of
Haddonfield residents which I'll point
out throughout this lesson first example
in 1963 Michael had a one-piece clown
suit a mask and a knife and he targeted
a teenager who had been getting busy
with her boyfriend so in 1978 the legend
would continue with Michael obtaining a
one-piece jumpsuit a mask and a knife
and he would once again Target teenagers
who are trying to do the act as
stand-ins for Judith he runs a mechanics
truck off the road and asks him to get
the suit to make this Knight a tribute
to his last Rampage he steals Judas
Tombstone from the Cemetery he breaks
into the General Store to steal a
Halloween mask and also gets some rope
which he would use later in addition to
picking up his now signature weapon a
couple of knives his next stop is his
childhood home which now sits abandoned
it is here that he gets hungry and eats
part of a dog and it is also here that
he first encounters Lori Stroud a high
school student who is there to drop off
a set of keys for her father who is a
realtor trying to sell the property he
follows her around all day until he
arrives at her babysitting job that
evening her friend Annie is babysitting
across the street and she becomes the
next victim Michael hides in her car so
when she goes to pick up her boyfriend
he strangles her before she gets out of
the garage his next victims are Bob and
Linda who are trying to use the house as
a private place to do their thing he
arranges all three dead teams in the
upstairs bedroom with Annie on the bed
under the Judith Myers Tombstone making
it clear that he's trying to recreate
the scenario from his youth he stuffs
Linda into a cupboard and hangs Bob
overhead in the closet then he kills the
lights in the house and waits for Lori
to notice and come over to check on her
friends when she does she's demonstrably
Disturbed but her next find is even more
horrifying foreign
[Music]
slowly but methodically chases her back
across the street to the doyle household
and makes several more attempts on her
but she puts up a good fight for
stabbing him in the neck with a knitting
needle then poking his eye out with a
clothing hanger and finally stabbing him
in the chest with the knife he dropped
but Michael Myers is Far From Any
ordinary man and Rises back to life in
an almost vampire-like fashion he gets a
hold of his exhausted prey finally
seeing his chance to end it by
strangling her but she does something
unexpected by removing his mask this
causes him to stop momentarily and he
attempts to put it back on before
continuing to attack her his fixation
with the mask is never detailedly
explained but it's obviously an
important part of the process for him in
the original timeline I analyzed The
Mask as an important part of the
ritualistic practice that he's taking
part in but here in the 40-year timeline
Michael is simply an escaped mental
patient it's a common occurrence for
mental patients to respond poorly to any
change outside their comfortable normal
that's why mental institutions never
deviate from having simple white walls
with no decorations the staff are always
dressed identically with the same
inoffensive music played every day the
same old boring facility actually
actually creates a calm safe environment
for the patient we also see this with a
character in the 40-year timeline Mr
tavoli he has a fixation with tied
shoelaces and anything else is upsetting
to him Michael was wearing a mask and
one piece costume when he killed his
sister in 1963. so he feels a need to
wear a similar attire mask included to
kill during the anniversary here in 1978
and the same would be true in the future
but this little distraction ends up
being a much larger detour
shot syndrome to this point this would
be the most damage that haddonfield's
boogeyman had ever taken on and it came
at the hands of his own psychiatric
doctor but it doesn't keep him down for
long he only needs a couple seconds to
flee the scene and cut through an alley
to escape he's spotted by a timid young
officer Frank Hawkins who shoots at him
but in unphased Michael simply walks
away out of sight it seems that the
first thing he does after this is move
his car because we can see it right here
parked outside the old Myers house
combine that with the breathing we hear
at the end of Halloween while looking
across the street at the house and it
seems likely that this was the first
place he went if you think about it it
makes sense that he tried to repark the
car because he was just attacked by Dr
Loomis who is the most likely person to
recognize that car Michael goes back out
on foot and comes across a boy named
Lonnie Elam who had tripped on the
sidewalk Michael doesn't kill kids and
he sees a pair of police officers
approaching so once again he
miraculously disappears something he's
managed to do a number of times now he
Retreats into his old home and stands at
the window just as he did as a child the
officers are McCabe who Michael had play
dates with in their youth and Frank
Hawkins who he had just encountered not
long before they investigate the house
where Michael surprises McKay when one
of the few times we ever see him run he
slams the officer into the wall several
times and uses the remainder of the Rope
taken from the hardware store to
strangle it we see McCabe managed to get
in several good punches in the abdomen
but Michael hardly seems to notice and
he just takes him hostage before Hawkins
gets into the room and shoots with the
rookie officer accidentally hits his
partner rather than the mass perpetrator
Michael drops his meat shield and calmly
walks out of the house even as several
more shots are being fired at him this
entire night he's been trying to
recreate the circumstances of his first
kill in 1963 and he brings it all to a
close by walking out of the house and
standing in the front yard just as he
did back then this time he is
immediately surrounded by six armed
police officers who are able to beat him
down and capture him and return him to
captivity this time in prison shortly
after Myers began his term in the state
prison he was transferred from medium to
maximum security because he apparently
formulated escape plans he also forged
his own identification credentials took
notes on airplane schedules and somehow
acquired road maps and a driver's
license after shooting him six times
Loomis was removed from his position as
Michael Myers doctor whether this was
voluntary or involuntary is does not
know in a statement recorded in audio on
January 22nd 1979 about three months
after the babysitter murders He suggests
that Myers should get the death penalty
this termination
death it's the only solution however the
state wanted to keep Michael alive to be
studied hoping they could gain more
insight on the mind of a killer this is
probably why he was eventually returned
to Smith's Grove I like to think I'm
doing a much better job of that in this
video than they did in their 55 years of
study but as I mentioned Michael is more
of an Essence than an actual character
we can assume Loomis knew this and kept
watch over Michael with only the
intention of keeping him locked up
however he eventually passed away and
his successor would not have the same
intention the next psychiatrist assigned
to look over Michael is a man by the
name of Dr Ranbir Satay Dr Sartain
became obsessed with trying to
understand Michael and his motives and
abilities this causes Sartain to develop
a bond to his patient and become
protective of him in the same way that
an artist might defend their life's work
he brought in over 50 clinical
psychiatrists to try to see Michael and
each had different opinions about him
during these 40 years Michael rarely
speaks which Sartain sees as a personal
choice to stay silent rather than a
disability in the years of Michael's
second stint of captivity Smith's Grove
sanitarium became Smith's drove state
hospital patients are calmed with old
jazz Music On Vinyl Records a Courtyard
area is outfitted to give them their own
space and get some fresh air and
sunshine every day and Sartain meets
individually with patients to check in
with them on a morningly basis after 40
Years of not much progress Michael was
set to be transferred to a new facility
glass Hill and assigned a new doctor on
October 30th 2018. the 40-year mark from
the date of his first Escape
[Music]
there are not many visitors for Smith's
Grove's most infamous resident so Dr
Sartain doesn't have many opportunities
to see how Michael reacts to different
people or different environments I
imagine this feels quite limiting to him
and speculate that when British
investigative journalist Aaron Corey and
Dana Haynes approached him about
speaking to Michael he gleefully
accepted with hopes of seeing a new side
of his mysterious long-studied mental
case they were able to arrange a meeting
just before the transfer on October 29
2018.
there he is when introduced to the
reporters Michael ignores them so in
order to try to elicit a response he
brings out the William Shatner mask that
was worn during the 1978 Rampage but it
manages to aggravate just about every
other patient than the one it was
intended for the evening of the 30th
each of the transferring patients were
lined up and loaded into a cage School
Bus outfitted by the Illinois Department
of Correction seriously Dr Sartain sees
him through to the end and tries to
comfort him something that seems
unnecessary given that Michael is a
well-established sociopath
by your side he even fights to go with
on the bus arguing that Myers is his
patient until he's been delivered into
someone else's care during the ride the
bus crashes into a ditch on Marlow Road
my theory is that Lori was the one to
drive the bus off the road in hopes of
killing Michael but things do not go
according to plan she's very unstable
and we do see her in her car overseeing
the patient transfer plus she hardly
seems to react when the accident is
reported on the news someone presumably
Michael after being freed by Sartain
attacks and seriously injures the guards
and bus driver allowing the patients to
escape into the middle I say this
because Dr Sartain had previously
expressed frustration and the fact that
so many clinical psychiatrists had
looked at Michael but only one Dr Loomis
had gotten to study him in the wild when
a father and son drive up and discover
the accident they both end up getting
out of the car to look around Michael
brutally snapped the neck of the father
and stealthily stowed himself away in
their back seat the kid encounters the
injured guard who just urges him to run
leading me to believe that Michael was
in fact the one to attack him showing
off the Unstoppable power that had faded
into Legend over the last 40 years and
that Legend was playing out once more
because Michael takes the kid out by
surprise choking him when he gets back
into the vehicle just as he did with
Annie in 1978 this also allows him to
steal that vehicle like he did during
that first escape to continue with the
tradition his first stop in Haddonfield
is at the cemetery where his sister
Judith is buried he finds the reporters
from the previous day recording more
content at the Judith Meyer's gravesite
and decides to follow them to the gas
station in order to get his mask back
while Aaron is not looking Myers walks
into the mechanic shop punches him out
and steals a suit he also bashes an
additional employees face in and Pockets
his teeth so he can drop them over the
bathroom stall that Dana is using to
scare the [ __ ] out of her pun kinda
intended Aaron realizes what's happening
just in time before his partner is
killed but even whacking Michael in the
face with a crowbar is not enough to
save her and both of their lives are
taken allowing Michael to reclaim his
prized Mass he would only need one more
item to finish his iconic look and he
would waste no time getting it because
it's Halloween nights he Blends in with
the crowd in costume allowing him to fly
under the radar just like his last
Rampage he bumps into some little kids
but lets them go even though one kid
comes really close to dropping an F-bomb
let's go oh
he steals a hammer from the El Rod shed
and he uses it against Mrs Elrod so he
can claim her kitchen knife and with
that the look is complete after 13
Halloween films I've come to appreciate
just how important Michael's appearance
is when it comes to making a mascara
antagonist and there's a good reason for
that it goes back to the root reason we
are drawn to horror movies human
psychology Danny McBride was onto
something when he described what makes
Michael scary to him he noted the
contrast between the horrible acts that
Michael commits and the lack of emotion
that he seems to have while committing
them this is called incongruent affects
the literal definition of this term is
when feelings mood or emotion do not
match up in Psychology incongruent
affect is when a patient's feelings do
not match their appearance or do not
match what is appropriate for the
situation it's fitting that the First
costume we ever see Michael in is the
clown costume because clowns are the
perfect example of incongruent affects
many people find them creepy because
their painted smile gives them the
appearance of always being happy even if
they are not happy or the situation does
not call for happiness that's why seeing
a clown at the circus probably isn't so
creepy if done correctly because the
circus is a happy place and the clowns
are trying to be funny but seeing a
clown in a sewer gray standpipe or
abandoned house is definitely creepy
that's incongruent effect it comes off
as creepy because we as humans are
designed to socialize with other humans
humans have traditionally lived in
tribes with other humans for safety so
socialization meant survival as a result
our brains have evolved for millions of
years to get really good at picking up
on social cues that's why outlets look
like a phase that's why cars look like a
phase that's why Iggy Pop's torso looks
like it's about to cry we are hardwired
to pick up on human emotions using only
visual cues when those cues don't match
up with what the person is really
feeling or don't match the situation we
pick up on that too because it tells us
that something is wrong perhaps it is a
predator trying to deceive us or there's
something wrong with the person and we
need to heal someone in our tribe seeing
Michael and slashing up victims all with
a blank expressionless stare is an
example of incongruent affects other
Halloween films which make Michael look
surprised or angry just don't have the
same effect and that's why it's
important for Michael to recollect all
of the pieces of his iconic look now
that he has the knife he's got to test
it out and he finds a suitable victim in
the house next door this victim seems to
be chosen at random but the next would
be chosen to maintain a tradition
established in 78. his main targets that
year were haddonfield's team babysitters
Annie and Lori this year he finds
another babysitter Vicky he was looking
after a boy named Julian Morrissey like
any good urban legend The Story begins
to repeat itself Michael sneaks into the
house and stares through Julian's
bedroom door but again isn't concerned
with killing kids it just freaks Julian
out and gets him to run down the stairs
for hell custom goblins shut up gave I
heard no breathing and then a song He's
in here boogeyman's in this house
Michael hides in the closet while the
room is vacated Vicky goes up to
investigate but doesn't find him there
because she's not taking Julian's
warning very seriously as she puts him
back to bed he asks her to close the
closet door but she finds something is
blocking it
Michael is undeterred by Vicky throwing
a chair at him so she rushes out of the
room but slips on the hardwood floor in
the hallway allowing him to drag her
back into the room and bring the knife
down on her after taking her out he
[ __ ] his head something we saw him do
after killing Bob Sims 40 years prior
this moment is explained by the actor
behind the mask in Nick Castle he plays
Myers in the original Halloween and in
parts of Halloween 2018. in an interview
with Entertainment Weekly he reveals
that director John Carpenter instructed
him to tilt his head like that on the
spot I had no idea what he was getting
at until I saw the movie and said oh how
cool it looks like I'm admiring my kill
which makes sense when paired with the
pinup model comparison I made in my
things you missed in Halloween video
it's almost as if the body pinned to the
wall is seen as a piece of artwork that
Michael is gawking at as we discussed
Michael is a mental patient and a
creature of habits which is why Castle
was instructed to perform the head tilt
again after killing Vicky or at least
that's how I see it I'm willing to close
the door on that mystery
actually everything he does before
leaving the house is a callback to his
Bob Sims kill he covers Vicky's body
with the bed sheets the same disguise he
used for himself after finishing Bob and
then his next victim is Vicky's
boyfriend Dave who he pins to the wall
with his knife just as he did to Bob
Frank Hawkins now a deputy in his 60s
shows up to investigate the disturbance
and finds Vicky but Michael is hiding in
a bedroom on the opposite side of the
house looking out the window through the
reflection of this mirror he makes eye
contact with Lori the one 17 year old
girl who invaded him the last time he
was free now at 57 she's more prepared
and fires a shot in his Direction which
might have at least dealt a blow to his
head if she had realized she was looking
through a mirror Michael walks out of
the house drawing the attention of
Hawkins but he cannot land a shot either
the discovery of Dave's Body distracts
his attention so Michael is once again
able to walk out and disappear into the
black of the night but this time is
different this time Lori spots him and
fires a shot through the left side of
his back before he completely disappears
this is the first time that Lori has
turned the tables on him and become the
hunter rather than the hunted only
Loomis was able to previously scare
Michael away up to this point he
Retreats and manages to get away and and
take cover within the Fortress of the
elrad's backyard which is surrounded by
high concrete walls but eventually a new
victim falls into his lap
[Music]
high school student Oscar Bellucci is in
a vulnerable state after getting drunk
and rejected by his crotch and mistakes
Michael for Mr Elrod the yard is
illuminated by these motion sensored
lights but each time they go off Michael
somehow manages to creep closer hey uh
where'd you go man you're acting dude
you're acting like really sketchy right
now logically it doesn't make sense that
Michael should be able to move without
turning the lights back on while Oscar
can but if there's any ability that
seems focused on the most in this
version of Michael's character it is his
ability to disappear part of what makes
him so scary and unique is that despite
being a huge immovable Force he's
incredibly sneaky he could be waiting
behind any corner or hiding within any
Shadow ever since Lori first spotted him
outside her classroom window there are
many instances where he'll be there one
moment but gone the next perhaps he
really does have a power to move without
being seen and this allows him to get
the best of Oscar and stick a knife into
his back before he's able to climb over
the El Rod's fans when Oscars Crush
Allison Nelson comes back after hearing
the commotion the lights turn on again
and Michael comes out to greet her
[Music]
she runs away and gets help from the
police so Michael ends up going for a
stroll he spotted and reported on 11th
Street near Saint Park where he
encounters a police SUV carrying Hawkins
Sartain and Allison upon seeing the
scourge of Haddonfield Hawkins floors it
Michael continues to walk right towards
the vehicle until the point of impact
demonstrating the complete lack of fear
he saw towards bodily injury Hawkins
Rams Michael with the vehicle knocking
him to the sidewalk where he's
temporarily knocked out to this point
we've seen Michael get knocked out a few
times all of them during the 1978
Rampage he goes down after getting his
neck punctured after getting stabbed in
the eye and chest and finally after
getting shot off a balcony each time
this happens he lays there until he can
regain the strength to continue his
spree something that I refer to as his
recharge period this scene is the first
time we see Michael recharge in 2018
which represents a terrifying
possibility earlier we saw him get shot
in the chest and continue walking like
nothing happened the fact that it takes
a hit from a 5 000 pound Chevrolet to
put him down means he may have become
even stronger during his years of
captivity or if we're going by the
theory that Lori would later suggest
each of his kills adds to his power
the more he kills the more he transcends
into something else impossible to defeat
when I covered Michael's history in the
original timeline I discussed the
possibility that he has the capability
to kind of bear down and hold off the
recharge for a little bit in critical
situations it's possible that this is
what happened here as well after getting
shot he held off doing a recharge until
the vehicular impact knocked him out
cold this is also the longest he's ever
been sidelined for he's out for four
minutes and 45 seconds more than twice
as long as his longest nap to this point
during this time Deputy Hawkins is
prepared to shoot him in the head but Dr
Sartain gets out to protect the subject
of his life's research when Hawkins
refuses to stand down Sartain attacks
him and drags Michael into the cabin of
the vehicle where Allison is currently
locked he heads towards Lori strode's
house hoping to see a reunion between
the two Michael's pursuit of Laura's
throat could be what keeps him alive
I would suspect the notion of being a
predator or the fear of becoming prey
keeps both of them alive Lori had
previously expressed a similar sentiment
about her rival he waited for this night
he's waited for me I don't know if her
interpretation is accurate but if it is
the way it would not have to go on much
longer Michael comes too in the back of
the cop car and kicks through the
partition hard enough to basically
immobilize him keep in mind these
partitions are made of steel and they're
literally designed to keep officers in
the front seats say from whatever unruly
criminals that they're arresting the
fact that Michael destroys this barrier
in one kick is insane he drags his
doctor out of the car allowing Allison
the chance to escape but Michael doesn't
seem to mind because he's mostly
concerned with stomping sartain's face
he crushes the man's head with one hard
stop more evidence that v-shape has kept
himself in shape he's not skipping like
that yeah take a good look at that one
Mikey he proceeds to make a quick work
of the two cops on standby outside of
Lori's house one gets his throat slashed
with the pen blade acquired from Sartain
and the other just straight up gets
turned into a manolander no not that
kind of Mana Lantern this kind looks
almost just as painful Michael Parks the
cop car outside of Lori's house and gets
the attention of her son-in-law at so he
also gets whacked when Michael chokes
him with the chain if we were to give
this one a 1978 counterpart it would be
Linda vanderk who get strangled with the
telephone cord and stored in a closet
which is exactly where Michael leaves
right but first he's gotta break into
the house
the surprising move nearly kills Lori it
makes me think back to an earlier part
of the movie where police told citizens
to stay inside and lock their doors when
Michael Myers is on the loose there's
really no reliable line of defense
because even Lori's Fortress is not
enough to withstand Michael's Brute
Force she's able to raise her shotgun in
his Direction and perhaps in an effort
to keep the Blast away from his head he
grabs the end of the barrel and gets his
two fingers blasted off it happens very
quickly and obviously I have to blur it
so that the YouTube Boogeyman doesn't
come for me in the night but you can see
right here as he's letting go Michael is
now down to three remaining fingers this
is a good time to talk about how Michael
handles injuries in this timeline
obviously Michael is nearly Invincible
there's only one way to kill him and
nothing else seems to affect him much
but it's still possible for him to get
scars and each of his major injuries
throughout the story visibly leaves a
mark on him the first is when Lori gets
in with the knitting needle the scar can
be seen on his neck at the hospital Lori
also Jabs his eye with a coat hanger
after the prisoner escape you can spot a
quick glimpse of the eye and it's
clouded over as if to suggest that he's
lost Vision on that side he's also
stabbed and shot in the Torso we haven't
had the Halloween Beach OVA yet but if
we ever did see him shirtless I'm sure
those scars would show up as well that's
what the Michael Myers fan girls had in
mind when they first heard the title
Halloween H2O but the point is it
probably would have been smarter for him
to just grab the end of the gun without
covering the cap because he has
permanently left with three fingers on
his left hand this handicap doesn't
really slow him down too much but it
stands the reason that you could reduce
him into a non-threat if you eventually
removed all of his limbs or something
this is contrary to the original
timeline and the 20-year timeline where
he gets shot in both eyes and blown up
and he just seems to regenerate and
eventually he looks fine the setback
doesn't stop him from breaking into the
house as Lori retreats to the basement
to shoot up at him through the
floorboards instead of going straight
for her he takes this time to put away
Rey's body as I mentioned earlier he may
not be a nice guy but at least he keeps
things tight Lori searches the house for
him and finds him in an upstairs bedroom
nearly identical to the one that they
fought in 40 years ago but for the
second time now she is the aggressor and
as Dr Sartain predicted they're both
vying for that role of the predator in
78 Michael came after her with a knife
but she was eventually able to use it
against him now Lori is the one armed
with a knife but it is Michael who finds
a way to use it against her
she also bites his hand or his throat
yet hungry but this time Lori is the one
to get thrown off the balcony so Michael
turns his attention to her teenage
granddaughter
Alison comes home hoping to find safety
in her grandmother's protection but
Michael hears her come in first however
this brief distraction gives Lori enough
time to pull another trick out of
Michael's book and disappear he heads
downstairs to try to finish off Lori's
bloodline who are hiding in the basement
Lori's daughter Karen begs her mom to
come help her but it's a trap gotcha
in the face Lori uses this opportunity
to emerge from the shadows and attack
Michael does land a blow against her
with a fire poker but the tussle ends
with her grabbing a frying pan to knock
him down into the basement so this
triggers the second recharge period of
the night it's only a few seconds but
that's just enough for Allison and Karen
to climb to safety and shut the bars
over the only exits Michael finds
himself in a basement-sized cage of
Lori's design she's turned out to be a
much more formidable rival than he
remembers her she opens the gas valves
throughout the house and all he can do
is stare as she tosses the flare down
into the basement to ignite Ablaze on
the man that haunted her nightmares for
her entire adult's life still Michael is
unflinching as the room explodes around
him his empty eyes locked onto her just
as they were since the very beginning
one of the benefits of living in a small
town is that it doesn't take long for
the fire department to arrive at least
it's usually a benefit one of
haddonfield's finest falls through the
floorboards into the seemingly empty
basements like a spider with a fly in
its web Lori's gun closet opens to
reveal Michael Meyer he brutally uses
the firefighter's own Halligan bar
against him shattering his protective
mask asking face his Mayday call sends
another firefighter on the way to offer
a hand of rescue but Michael emerges
from the smoke to yank him into the
basement as well the efforts of the
emergency crew combined with the
collapsing structure of the house create
a path of escape and the shape appears
at the doorway it's v-shape charred from
the trap that Lori had left him to die
in but stoic as ever as he clasps his
new weapon with the eight fingers that
he has left the group of firefighters is
well equipped to fight back with axes
Circle Saws and the power of numbers on
their side but Michael methodically
destroys each of them all in all Michael
tears through 11 men 11 dead bodies
they're all First Responders Perhaps it
is as the young Tommy Doyle suggested so
many years ago
he can't kill the boogeyman but as I
discussed he's not immune to injury and
he's still nursing that left hand he
sneaks into the home of Phil and Sandra
Larson and raids their bathroom for
first aid supplies a small drone crash
lands in the bathroom and probably not
knowing what it is he throws it out into
the living room getting the attention of
the terrified homeowners when Phil comes
in and turns the lights on he briefly
sees Michael with a disinfectant a
soiled washcloth and bandages spread out
across the sink Michael immediately
smashes the light and Phil locks the
door but Michael Powers his way through
a glass window and bludgeons him against
the wall before pulling him down through
the glass shards to puncture his neck he
does this all almost entirely with his
good hand only bringing his bandage hand
up at the end to help grip Phil's head
he is quickly learning how to be
resourceful with his remaining finger
Sandra takes hold of a small kitchen
knife to defend herself but Michael has
another idea and Dismounts the
fluorescent tube light from above the
stove
hahaha
he sticks it right through her neck and
sweats before leaving the house Michael
tosses Phil's still not dead body onto
the table in the kitchen and sticks
knife after knife into him until he
finally finds one he likes and walks
outside having taped up his hand and
having acquired a new knife Michael
makes his way home but he would have to
go across town to get there he wanders
the streets of Haddonfield as the clock
rolls over into the early hours of
November 1st 2018. he goes through a
park where he is reportedly up to his
usual stalking antics where did you see
him he's just hiding behind trees and he
pops out like peekaboo I mean we're not
three years old come on man when one of
the kids wanders from the group Michael
gets in without the others noticing we
don't see it but we do see the kid's
mask dripping in the aftermath these
kids appear to be young teenagers maybe
13. so I'm guessing that Michael really
does draw the line regarding who he's
willing to kill between teenagers and
pre-teens he spots another face from his
past talking to the other two teens this
is Lindsay Wallace the same girl that
Annie was babysitting before being
killed by Michael 480 months before
that's 40 years I just wanted to change
things up because I feel like I keep
saying that he also discovers an SUV
containing Marion Chambers and two other
passengers mimicking what he did to her
in 1978 he climbs on top of the vehicle
and grabs her through the window but
this time she's armed and tries to shoot
at him through the roof when he comes
down to meet her face to face she's got
a line prepared for him hey Michael
this is for Dr Loomis uh yes let's
avenge Dr Loomis the one guy who
seemingly died of natural causes in this
timeline fortunately for Michael her
tribute to her former colleague doesn't
work out because she's out of bullets
he climbs into the window and stabs her
four times before he strangled with a
prop stethoscope by the man in the back
seat Michael is not affected by this at
all and sticks the knife into the man's
left eye putting in ends to the struggle
maybe Michael picked that one up from
Lori Stroud the man's wife comes back
towards the vehicle with a handgun and
Michael's quick thinking results in a
kill that would probably be more at home
in an FPS Montage than a Halloween movie
history
as Michael does his trademark corpse
admiration had tilt he gets a surprise
bag of bricks to the face from Lindsay
despite being one of the four survivors
of the babysitter murders she vastly
underestimates him and he chokeslams her
against the car however her experience
does help her because she's able to use
the same tactic that Laurie once used to
get away from his grip by removing the
boogeyman's mask after readjusting it he
follows her into the woods at his
customary walking pace we are now moving
at the speed of pretty slow but somehow
intimidated shortly thereafter the
couple from the SUV is somehow moved to
the Carousel at the park and Marianne is
decorated with the witch Mass left
behind by the teens and hung from the
top of the swing set we literally see
Michael leave the scene to look for
Lindsay so the only explanation is that
he went back to rearrange their bodies
which to be fair is consistent with his
character Annie Linda and Bob were also
arranged in the scene in 78 and he also
pays special attention to the
presentation of Vicky and Rey earlier on
this night in 2018. seeing this trend
repeated so many times makes me
automatically start searching for a
reason behind it as with many aspects of
his character will probably never ever
get a definitive answer so all I can do
is use the clues and speculate the first
scene was clearly a recreation of his
sister's gravesite which is something
that happened when Michael was a kid and
this one depicts the bodies playing at a
playground somewhere you would usually
find kids Michael was a child during his
first killing and we know he has
psychological issues he's been in a
mental hospital for 55 years maybe his
childhood trauma prevented him from
maturing out of a childlike mindset
maybe he sees these bodies as toys that
he can play with and maybe he avoids
killing kids because he sees them as one
of his own kind his next destination
would also play into this idea because
Michael Myers would return to his
childhood home
the first time Michael broke out of
Smith's Grove he visited his former
residence and found it abandoned it was
in a dilapidated state but other than
the natural effects of time it was
unaltered this time the property no
longer sat empty he would find it
occupied by two men Big John and little
John he sneaks in through the back door
probably because this was the entrance
that he used shortly before killing
Judah I also find it interesting that he
leaves behind a three-fingered handprint
on the door frame it almost looks like a
dinosaur track which seems appropriate
given Tommy's speech at the hospital he
is an apex predator the way Dr Sartain
describes him Compares him to another
apex predator a shark
he only knows how to keep moving and to
keep killing and you will kill again
unless he's captured this is actually no
mistake in an interview with
halloweenmovies.com and director David
Gordon green explains how he used Jaws
almost like a template for this
iteration of Michael Myers in some ways
it's like a film like Jaws there's not a
lot of personality in the shark
technically he's very Elusive and we're
trying to keep that as our framework and
not get too much into who he is why he
is or what he's been doing it sounds
like this approach was also communicated
to mask designer Christopher Nelson and
it ended up being this very strange
mannequin-like soulless almost great
white shark of a human in the scenario
much like the opening scene of Jaws the
Predator stalks its prey silently
Michael sneaks around upstairs to get
the draw on Big John without ever being
noticed and squeezes his eyes out of
their sockets just for good measure
after this Michael resumes the position
he took as a child just staring out his
sister's bedroom window when little John
addresses him he turns and approaches it
is not long before he joins his partner
in death
he poses the remains of the two Johns
just like a photo found in their study
only their positions are switched I
don't have time to explain the
significance of that here but watch my
things you missed in Halloween kills
after this if you're interested another
trait of Michaels that we've seen come
up time and time again is his love of
Darkness there's one I can relate to we
saw him turn off all the lights after
taking over The Wallace house in 1978
and he follows suit here after
reclaiming his own residence this makes
it easier for him to hide in the shadows
and Hunt his prey the next victim is
Lonnie Elam the kid that Michael briefly
encountered just outside the Meyer's
house after escaping from Dr lumens now
that he's no longer a kid he's a
perfectly viable Target he makes quick
work of Lonnie and throws him into the
attic then hides in the closet and waits
for someone to come looking for him and
that someone is Lonnie's teenage son
Cameron Michael burst out of the closet
and pins him to the wall where he's able
to stab him several times Cameron's
girlfriend Allison Comes Marching with a
shotgun which he easily deflects but
she's able to land several knife Jabs
into his stomach before he slams her
face into a railing and tosses her down
the stairs as he finishes Cameron
Allison challenges him to come get her
in hopes of creating a distraction but
he doesn't come for her until after
breaking Cameron's neck with a 180
degree twist Allison is nowhere near a
match for Michael's quick reflexes and
strength but she's saved when her mom
shows up and stabs Michael in the back
with the Pitchfork found on the front
porch this is actually one of the most
effective attacks we've ever seen
against him he actually appears to
recoil in pain for a moment as he is
driven to the ground what makes this
Pitchfork so effective as opposed to the
stabs and gunshots he's endured all
night long in my opinion this goes back
to the recharge period imagine Michael
is like a Pokemon just hang with me for
a second here he has a set amount of
Health Points each attack against him
will lower his HP but they won't slow
him down until his bar reaches zero once
that happens he faints and has to rest
for a little while before his health is
restored at which point he can go on
fighting again you can make him faint
all he wants but that doesn't mean he's
going to die he's not scary's radicate
so the Pitchfork and the subsequent
headstomp was probably just the final
blow the last of Michael's HP this
recharge period is pretty short that way
just long enough for Karen to steal
Michael's mask which tracks now as a
well-tested method to distract him from
anything else he totally ignores the
vulnerable Allison and walks after Karen
who goads him on through backyards and
side yards into another Street which
turns out to be yet another trap he's
surrounded by an angry mob of
Haddonfield townspeople and their
obnoxiously big trucks cars they're led
by Lee Brackett the father of the
babysitter Annie whose life he famously
cut short 40 years before and by Tommy
Doyle the boy that Lori was babysitting
during her encounter with Michael that
same night the mob is armed with
Firearms hockey sticks shovels pipes
baseball bats and one lady even brings
an iron not a golf club but like a
clothing iron for some reason with
Michael surrounded they're able to
overwhelm him by attacking from his
Blind Side burying close range shots
into him and turning up the Beatdown
once he hits the pavement he drops his
knife and barely Has the strength to
reach for it so Karen the woman whose
life was spent preparing for my
Michael's onslaughts grabs it and
slashes it into his upper back it looks
like it may be over for Michael that he
had finally met his match just to be
sure bracket lines up his gun to Meyer's
head but in one quick motion the evil
being draws the knife from his own back
and uses it to slash through bracket's
throat from here Michael's abilities
seem to grow Laurie Strode has the
theory about Michael's tendency to
seemingly become more and more difficult
to defeat she believes that the more he
kills the more he transcends into
something impossible to take down I
guess my Pokemon analogy is actually
perfect to describe this too in Pokemon
the more monsters you defeat the more
experience you gain which eventually
levels you up after taking out Lee
brackets Michael seems to get a boost in
his abilities and the same attackers he
was overwhelmed by moments earlier are
now outmaneuvered overpowered and with a
little bit of luck come on people of
Haddonfield you gotta learn to keep
track of how much ammunition you have
left he takes down each of them until
it's just him and Tommy when Michael
deals the finishing blow the two lock
eyes sorta Michael looks into Tommy's
eyes but Tommy can only see the dark
voids of Shadow created by the mask when
covered by The Mask under the fall of
night the facial features that make him
human and just aren't visible another
example of incongruent affect with the
entire mob taken care of Michael returns
to his post sneaking past the commotion
of emergency vehicles and crime scene
investigators to return to Judith's old
bedroom he finds Karen standing at his
spot gazing out the window but by the
time she notices him in the reflection
it's already too late for her Karen is
killed and the shape retakes his
rightful place atop Haddonfield
how does a crime like Michael's affect
him
that feeling
is you on a random path or is he
emotionally driven triggered by
something
perhaps some unheard marching order
imprinted on his very being I want to
know what he's feeling I wanna know what
pleasure he gets out of killing Dr
Sartain in his quest to understand the
mind of a killer nearly became a killer
himself he wanted to gain more insight
into Michael by observing him in the
wild as misguided as this may have been
could it be argued that seeing Michael
break free for a third time helps us
understand him helps us identify his
patterns helps us understand the mind of
a killer maybe it's up to your
interpretation if any of the analysis
provided in this video or any of your
own conclusions holds any more ground
than any of the 50 psychiatrists who
examined him in captivity personally to
this point I feel pretty good about all
of my teachings here in this lesson but
I'd still hesitate to call them
definitive mostly because of what
happens next just when we think we're
starting to understand Michael the
pattern breaks he doesn't go back into
captivity as you would expect this time
Michael gets away
foreign
hunt for suspected killer Michael Myers
continues in Haddonfield Illinois on
Friday two days after 27 people were
brutally killed on Halloween night the
suspect Michael Myers 61 is believed to
have fled the area and is currently at
large he is in possession of a knife and
considered armed and very dangerous
that's what newspapers read in early
November after Michael Myers worst crime
spree yet however they were wrong about
two things the first being Michael's
kill cons they probably haven't even
tallied all the bodies yet because it's
more like 57 give or take a few whose
fate is never explicitly seen the second
error is that Michael did not
necessarily leave the area at this time
he most likely retreated to the sewers
where he could easily lay low while the
drama died down I imagine at some point
he tried to go back home but found his
old residence demolished and ended up
just staying in the sewer over the next
four years there were other Halloween
murders which were ultimately determined
to be inspired by Michael but not
committed by Michael himself there were
also people who went missing around
Halloween and never turned up like Megan
Baxter in October 2021. despite the fact
that police did not name Michael Myers
as a culprit for any of this it is
likely that he did take in a few victims
during this time based on the comments
of this homeless man who hangs out
around the sewer entrance
I bet you we have no way of knowing
which victims were taken by Michael and
which were taken by other people because
the police seem like they're just taking
educated guesses rather than getting
real evidence for some reason I think
he's come back
I really don't understand that logic
just because Michael has not fired a gun
in the past doesn't mean he isn't going
to he never killed anyone with a halogen
bar until he did plus one of his victims
did die from a gunshot even if he wasn't
the one to fire ants I'm guessing he
mostly just killed people near the sewer
entrance though in order to keep a lower
profile for example Megan Baxter's
missing billboard is right near this
overpass and it makes sense that they
would want to place this near the
location she was believed to have
disappeared so she probably was taken by
Michael in October 2022 a young man
named Corey Cunningham is tossed from
the overpass into the hobo camp where he
is abducted by Michael who drags him
into the sewer strangely he doesn't kill
Corey while he's passed out as he tries
to escape the sewers Michael reaches out
and tries to strangle him during which
they make eye contact and something
seems to be passed between the two and
Corey escapes we're not really given a
reason that Michael lets Corey live but
we are given a reason for Allison's
attraction decor
hey I know what it's like to have
everybody looking at you thinking that
they know you thinking that they know
what you've been through but they don't
so maybe Michael relates to Corey on a
similar level then on October 29th Corey
leads a police officer named Doug
mullaney into the sewer where Michael is
waiting for it Michael jumps officer
Melanie but Melanie is able to get the
upper hand and knock Michael to the
floor but Corey intervenes by attacking
mullaney and begs Michael to show him
how he kills Michael grabs a rusted old
knife probably the same one from the
Larson's house and Corey restrains
Melanie giving Michael the opportunity
to slash his throat and stab him over
and over we can see the life and power
return to Michael's body as he does this
and he stabs Melanie several times more
each with increasing Tempo in power it
appears that Lori's theory is partially
correct the more that Michael kills the
more powerful he becomes however at this
point he seems to be weaker than he was
in 2018. my first thought was that long
periods without killing can drain his
power however that doesn't exactly track
with his Escape four years prior he had
not killed anyone during his 40-year
stay at Smith's Grove yet he still had
the power to overtake the entire Bus
full of armed guards so it could be that
Michael's power is fading as he gets
older and he needs to continue to kill
in order to maintain his strength
another thought I'm stewing with is that
maybe killing is not what gives him his
power but maybe his status as the
boogeyman is what gives him power this
would explain why his power builds
through 1978 but Lorry the one character
who doesn't believe in the boogeyman
survives then in 2018 his notoriety had
grown even greater we literally see
reporters coming to Haddonfield from
across the globe to investigate him with
each victim he took that year he became
even more Infamous which makes it appear
as if each kill is actually powering him
up but then in 2019 Corey Cunningham
killed the kid he was babysitting and he
became the new villain of Haddonfield
Michael was now sharing the boogeyman
Spotlight and some of that power went to
Corey not to Michael
seen his eyes Michael's eyes in Corey
the one snag in this theory is that he
kills officer mullaney in private before
the town learns about his death we see
the power immediately go back into
Michael however there is one witness to
this Corey even if he's just an audience
of one Michael is still bringing life
back into the urban legend which in turn
literally gives life to the legend
himself it's something I brought up
several times throughout his history so
Michael's status as an urban legend may
be important here as well after this
Michael follows Corey who goes back to
Lori's new house where he Witnesses the
woman he's become all too familiar with
over the last 44 years spying in her own
windows at a young couple much like he
did as a child the next night he follows
Corey again this time to the home of Dr
Mathis Alison Dental boss he watches as
the young man in the Scarecrow mask
takes him out Corey is unable to reach
mathis's girlfriend before she locks him
out of the house but Michael is already
there waiting for her he puts his full
power on display for the first time in
four years by pinning her up against the
wall with his knife as he had with Bob
Sims and Dave in the past earlier I
talked about Michael's head tilt being a
sign that he's admiring his kill like
artwork and the idea is furthered here
because Deborah is pinned up over a
large paint the next day is an important
one October 31st Halloween fell upon
Haddonfield once again and it would not
pass without their Infamous Boogeyman
paying them one final visits
Michael's favorite holiday begins on a
low note with Corey charging into the
sewers picking a fight with him pinning
into the ground and stealing his mask as
he does this he says you're just a man
in a Halloween mask perhaps he is able
to overpower Michael because of this
belief that he's nothing more than an
ordinary man he could not have been more
wrong
as we've seen it time and time again
Michael will stop at nothing to get his
mask back he somehow tracks Corey to
Lori strode's house and sneaks in
through the back door to reclaim his
mask once again by the Time Michael gets
there Corey appears to be laying dead in
the foyer but when the shape reaches
down to take his knife he Springs to
life and grabs Michael's hand it would
appear that Corey has just had his own
recharge period but I'll come back to
that a little bit later this time
Michael is the apex predator once more
and he snaps Corey's nag now he can turn
his attention back to Lori Strode for
one last Showdown he goes into the
kitchen drawn to the hum of the
microwave before hearing movement from a
closet before opening it the contents of
the microwave pops but the meal Michael
has served is not the one he was hoping
for because Laura uses the distraction
to bust out of the closet and knock the
knife loose from his hands using a fire
extinguisher how ironic that 11 fully
equipped firemen couldn't manage to
disarm Michael but little old Lori
Strode with a fire extinguisher could
however he's still able to grab hold of
her and smash her face against a china
cabinet he throws her down and Stomps
his boot onto her throat so that she
won't be able to get out of this one by
simply removing his mask because she
can't reach instead she retaliates by
kicking his other knee the tussle
continues on with one notable moment
being when Michael turns on the garbage
disposal and tries to force her hand
into it not only is this an homage to a
scene from Halloween H2O but from
Michael's point of view it's revenge for
their battle four years earlier where
Lori blasted off his fingers with the
shotgun this was probably the most
damage that anyone had ever done to him
because as I mentioned Michael can't
just grow back fingers in this timeline
so he's looking to get even with her by
mingling a few of hers however she's
able to get out of this with a
well-placed headbutt and there just
happens to be a knitting needle lying
around so she tries that attack again
seeing as how it worked in 1978 but this
time he is prepared once again he tries
to get his revenge on her by impaling
her face with the needle and this time
he is successful but it comes at a cost
because this time she does manage to get
close enough to remove his mask and the
momentary distraction allows her to pin
his hand to the counter with his own
knife leaving him only one arm to work
with she somehow manages to pin him down
to the kitchen island reach into her own
knife to Roar and drive the blade into
his heart ironically this leaves him in
a very similar position to the one he
left Phil Larson in for Halloween's
prior I discussed the possibility that
Michael can hold off the recharge period
sometimes and continue to power through
to get himself out of a critical
situation and I'm guessing that's what
happens here because it only takes four
seconds for him to sit up with so much
force that he throws Lori off of him
with it abundantly clear that she won't
be able to kill Michael or even slow him
down with recharge periods her only
option is to try to immobilize him what
she does by pinning his other hand down
to the counter with a knife and using
the frying pan like a hammer to push the
metaphorical nail into the metaphorical
crucifix he squirms when he realizes
he's now totally defenseless but just to
be safe Lori also topples her
refrigerator pinning his leg to the
island Michael is truly immobilized for
the first time even the Trap she left
him to die in at her old home still gave
him the freedom to move around the
basement and eventually Escape now he
could truly not go anywhere and Lori
takes advantage of the situation by
grabbing her chef's knife the tool that
Michael favored and used to destroy so
many families and forced him to look at
his own reflection one last time after
all if Deputy Hawkins interpretation is
to be believed Michael was never looking
out the window at the Myers house he was
looking in at his reflection Laurie Jabs
her rival on the side then one last time
removes his mask and looks into his real
face there's a supposed phenomena among
initial viewers of the original 1978
Halloween film many audience members
reported seeing a deformed face during
the scene where Laurie first removed his
mask but in reality it was just the
actual face of actor Tony Moran with
some spooky lighting and a small injury
prosthetic meant to represent the damage
that Lori had done with the coat hanger
in the prior scene I can only imagine
the blow to Tony's confidence was more
damaging than anything any Boogeyman can
do but the consensus is that because of
the atmosphere the audience was
projecting their expectations of horror
and their own fears when they watched
that scene the 2022 unmasking has the
opposite effect because Michael really
is kind of deformed at this point
through multiple stabs and gunshots to
the face and of course the blaze that
seemed to have melted his ear off and
left him with Burns that nearly rival
one Mr Frederick Krueger however this
time we don't get a direct look at his
face leaving part of the horror up to
the imagination of the viewer Lori
slashes cleanly through Michael's throat
with a sense of finality but Michael
Myers is truly even closer to
invincibility than even she believes he
has to rip his hand out of the knife
effectively splitting it in two but it
doesn't matter because he's still able
to grip his fingers around Lori's throat
a vice that she cannot escape from
strangely she seems to egg him on from
this position
[Music]
four years ago her granddaughter had a
similar line when Michael had her
cornered at the Myers house where the
death as the only visible outcome but it
turned out she was talking to her mother
who was standing behind him with a
pitchfork Lori's words here are also
directed at someone else this time it's
Allison who gets to play the Savior she
pulls Michael's arm away from her
grandmother and breaks it on the side of
the counter wow I did not think she had
that in her with her Airways now free
Lori slits Michael's wrist which he
seems to naively think is the end of him
when Deputy Hawkins arrives on the scene
with police
Michael Eastern
not dead enough I'm glad someone has
some common sense here it seems like
Allison's the only one who is aware of
the recharge period Michael is moved to
the roof of a vehicle and is tied down
with Rogue I would honestly go with
something a little bit sturdier knowing
Michael but that's just me police lead A
procession towards the junkyard and many
other Haddonfield residents join in to
ensure that there's no wiggle room for
Michael to pull some kind of miraculous
Escape as he had in 2018. he is untied
and involuntarily crowd surfed to the
industrial Shredder carefully he's a
villain in the end it is Lori the woman
who lost her best friends her daughter
her son-in-law and so many who were
close to her who rolls Michael's body
into the gears where it is completely
crushed and shredded into beds there
would be no tombstone no Memorial only
the legend of the boogeyman but even
with his body completely destroyed is
this the end of The Boogeyman maybe but
maybe not
[Music]
is this truly the end of Michael Myers
has the Halloween franchise finally run
its course sure they could always start
a new timeline Branch or do another
reboot but for the purposes of this
video let's focus on the 40-year
iteration of Michael Myers it is
certainly the end of Michael Myers the
man we've seen throughout this timeline
that his injuries are permanent and he
gets his entire body ripped to shreds so
there's no coming back from that but in
Halloween ends we saw Michael's evil
infect other people in the town of
Haddonfield it started with random
crimes on Halloween night but it really
took hold on Corey Cunningham who
started to go down the same path as
Michael eventually developing an
inexplicable desire for the mask and
even coming back from a mortal wound
after a short recharge period we don't
see what happens to him he's left lying
in Lori's foyer and we never find out if
he comes back to life again if you're
not familiar Halloween franchise
producer Mustafa akad created a special
clause in the contract for each
Halloween film The filmmakers were
legally not allowed to kill Michael
Myers so that akkad could continue
making money off the the IP forever
which he did there's a clause in the
contract with Mustafa akkad that says
you can't kill him
which is why Michael's apparent death in
H2O was retconned in Resurrection the
filmmakers made a deal with him where
they were allowed to make it look like
Michael had died but they had to undo it
at the start of the next film so they
came up with this whole scenario where
Michael switched costumes with the EMT
and that's whose head really got cut off
it's really done but it's also another
reason that Michael being unmastering
his death in Halloween ends is
significance because Lori can see that
she's actually killing the right guy
Mustafa akkad died in 2005 but I've
heard that his son malachikad includes
the same clause in his contracts I can't
help but wonder if the ambiguity behind
Corey Cunningham's fate was another deal
with the akad family Malik allows
Michael Myers to meet his end at 64
years old and in exchange Corey becomes
the new Michael Corey is 21 just like
Michael was during the original movie so
they could potentially start again from
there I'm not saying that's what I think
is going to happen it probably makes
more sense to just start another
timeline Branch or go back to the
Anthology franchise idea and do some
other stories that take place on
Halloween nights like what they did with
Halloween 3. that's personally what I
want to say but aside from the potential
contractual reason that it ended as it
did I think there's an artistic reason
as well perhaps this was the end that
David Gordon green and Danny McBride
wanted because of the message that it
sends perhaps they wanted us to feel
like the evil that drove Michael Myers
is Alive and Well in Corey Cunningham or
even in somebody else the opening
credits of Halloween and show a constant
cycle of jack-o-lantern rebirth and
there's also this scene where Lindsay
does tarot cards with Allison now that
just means a major phase is ending and
know what it's about to begin the most
overused phrase in this Trilogy was evil
dies tonight it's to the point that it
kind of became a meme but if there's
anything that I took away from the end
of this Michael's story it's that you
can stop one evil person but you can
never totally defeat evil there will
always be evil in the world there's no
point in turning your house into a
fortress and obsessively trying to stop
it because there will always be another
evil on the horizon if you enjoyed this
video I've also analyzed the original
timeline of Michael Myers so if you're
interested in how that character differs
from this one check out that video on
the left and if you love scary movies
that is exactly what I cover on this
channel so go ahead and subscribe to
cz's world for new Horrors every week
ring the death bell and select all
notifications so you don't miss any
uploads and I will see you in the next
one assuming we both survive